[Music]
sarah cooper everything's fine
[Laughter]
we're going to get things done to get
things done that they've wanted to see
done
for a long long time i would rather be
in the drunk tank
i'd rather be in a think tank with isis
well that puts it to rest never be said
women can't be funny
i think i think i'm sorry right no it's
just because you're so
angry i think it's my hope
is this when they take the oscar for
maddy mcdaniel
subject for today
[Music]
asian lawyer bill richmond is here
gerald a is here quarter black garrett
is here i still don't believe it but he
is shunned by all communities
that's a badge of honor sir uh we have a
lot
to talk about today yesterday we had
some technical issues and it was
technical issues also combined with the
fact that
last minute half asian bill richmond
thought he might have the kavid
i i was praying for it but the lord did
not
answer my prayers negative tests all
around but he did answer the prayers of
everyone who had lay hands so they were
like
there we go and we're planning a sketch
of a parody of drag me to hell where the
lady who curses the main actress uh
drips and balman
flew it onto her because i was like i'll
get coveted on air apparently we still
we're still searching yellow fever
i hope i find what i'm looking for uh we
have a lot to talk about today we'll be
talking about well why do you think the
polls are always wrong for some reason
the media they've been trying to say
that the polls were right in this
election
we'll be talking about thanksgiving and
importantly we will be talking about
one of the most common chats that we get
is what can you do
what can you do right now to resist
right because right now you are the
resistance and there are plenty of legal
acts of civil disobedience so it doesn't
have to be
do nothing and comply or civil war but
there are plenty of acts of civil
disobedience in which you can engage and
hey
uh the coppers the fuzz the popos you
can help support us with this
uh first fraud update um with sydney
powell
there is none the the kraken is really
more of a
it's a tepid calamari at this point
technically she's got the whole week yes
technically she has a whole week will be
since it's entirely speculation
we don't like to do that on youtube and
get removed we'll be talking about it on
mug club exclusively after this
lightweight.com slash mug club
you can subscribe try our election
stream still gives you 30
off still um and we have we have so much
to get to that's going on right now so
we do want to talk about thanksgiving i
know people are afraid and
the election fraud stuff is not going
anywhere uh
hopefully the legal team has their stuff
in order yeah i would hope i'm always
surprised
we haven't made the case that sydney
powell has but we were like if she
actually has this data
sure that would be surprising because we
don't well it is just tuesday
it is just tuesday it is just tuesday no
not and by the way
i don't think you'd need that i don't
think you need your minion voting
systems but it does seem a little at
this point
you do have to make sure that either
you're presenting something in court or
the american public will lose interest
because uh and i have some evidence i've
i've lost interest in
and i love rudy giuliani but not when
he's dripping
tripping brown met him too so giuliani
yeah i thought that was his like wwe
look where he was trying to be
intimidating or something
little rudy bear but first actually this
week uh the pope
met with nba players not dennis rodman
at this point he's not
nba players to discuss issues of social
justice and this is just too funny to
not look
a golden gold basketball is that really
a huge ferrero rocher big hazelnut
players have um you know done to
you know use our voice he can't
understand you
you know mumble rap it's everywhere now
what is this everything is just gold
about you're about to go oh magic
i was the first one to wait in movie
line for red shoes
they offered him uh gifts of gold
frankincense and
uh of course virginia racial divide a
blu-ray copy of madia's family christmas
so that is
gonna be watching the healing begins
italians don't have the same sense of
humor look look
when there's a common enemy we really
get together and yeah common enemy is
every medium
yes i don't understand americans what
where is this is not funny where is the
paper mache hat and red mouse
no it's like independence day and just
out of the alien ship comes media movies
and we're like all right guys we really
gotta get together hey by the way we're
talking about parlor too the media's
accused parlor of being racist we are
available
on parlor uh so you can follow us uh
follow me stephen crowder on parlor
right there
uh we have some major announcements
coming with social media in the coming
months but we can't talk about that
right now again why do you think polls
are all wrong and why do you think the
media is trying to say that the polls
were right but first let's go to
um acts of civil disobedience what are
they what are they talking about right
now on cnn really quickly
what's with poppy harlow in the shoulder
pads she's trying to make it a thing
does she say i only want a closet of
pirate shirts
or bridgette nielsen suits yeah you know
i don't know any if anybody's ever said
i love a woman with good broad shoulders
i like my women built like a brick out
house oh
no with a firm grip solid
i'd like my woman to eat uh crabs legs
alaskan king crab legs with their hands
which requires both a firm grip and
calluses um i want a wife that looks
like dwight howard yes
uniform um so this is the question
people have what can you do
and and i'm glad my half asian lawyer
bill richmond is here uh coveted free
with a lot of it you know we're going
into thanksgiving and there are these
lock downs
and people are saying well what can we
do at this point it seems like
everything is lost and it's not the
election is not over that's why we still
have the promo code
but you still do have the the far left
acting as though it's over and already
implementing these crazy lockdowns and
and trying to to bar you from
celebrating thanksgiving
here's the thing you haven't seen this
in the media there have been a lot of
acts of civil disobedience and it starts
with understanding your rights
it starts with understanding the bounds
of the law so that you can understand
where your local officials or in some
cases governors are actually not within
the parameters of the law or certainly
people coming in trying to shut down
your business
when they don't have that authority so
let's go through a few acts of civil
disobedience some of my favorites one of
which involves a crazy polish man
finally finally the crazy polox got one
right
uh this is in buffalo new york no one
cares polo looks like
it's true it's true however we were the
ones who said
stop with the muslim immigration jokes
on you
we win um
i don't know if i would say polish
[Music]
from buffalo new york sound midwestern
as you will see in this clip here are
some uh
not only business owners in buffalo new
york but there was a meeting of business
owners i think restaurant tours
specifically
which is an affected name you own a
diner
they said some cops came in and were
sent in and i think also
perhaps a health inspector i'm not sure
the role of this this professional karen
in chief
they were shutting down trying to shut
down this business
and they responded again and
understanding their rights this to me is
one of the most beautiful encapsulations
of you knowing your rights and civil
disobedience that all of us
can and i would encourage to be engaging
in you're on private property you need
to leave
we're asking you to kill your
compassionate side i know you're
taxpayers our tax dollars gear into your
guys's paychecks
but some of these people actually work
for their money and they don't want to
lose their livelihood
i've lost friends who've killed
themselves i've seen clients
die because they've lost their
livelihood i'm sorry to hear that i know
you are and i'm just a pal i'm asking
for you to guys have some compassion
for the people that have lost everything
we do have compassion for
people okay well you need to go have
compassion out in the parking lot
this is private property compassion get
your ass
i love how she reached into her holster
and pulled out a cell phone
it is a protest this is a waffle
protest and no one had to burn down a
race track or throw a molotov cocktail
into a buckle store
what's she calling cuomo hey they're not
listening
hey yeah that's like they're not
listening reaching into the suit jacket
and pulling out a notepad like
so there you go they understood no you
you don't have the authority to come in
here you are on private property
leave they didn't assault anybody they
didn't throw bricks they didn't hit
anyone in the back of the head with a
snare drum which although a creative
crime i do not advocate no
that's what makes an interesting sound
what is that sound gerald it actually
happens
there's one of these who hit a female
cop in a riot helmet with a snare drum
and she was like ah she was very
confused and she was more like did
someone start is there a
concert they didn't know about they
didn't get a permit no he's about to say
something i was gonna say that they
asked them they said okay well what is
the violation to the the karen and chief
as you pointed out and she said
oh it's anonymous he's like no
correct well you do in certain contexts
um
and and here's here's the thing is look
we're if you were a law enforcement
officer in this moment
you have a lot of things that you're in
a rock and a hard place in right which
is
you're sworn uphold the law whatever the
laws may be but however you have
the ability in the united states to
decide whether or not you're going to
actually
go and enforce something or not so what
is the pressure the pressure is coming
from
who who is at the top of every law
enforcement food chain in every
jurisdiction
politicians it's the politicians who are
saying you go and force these rules or
you'll be out on the street
you'll be on our livelihood so so i
liked how those
business owners spoke to them and even
raising their voice and like doing the
chanting that's all great stuff
it's communicating hey we're trying to
do our job yeah
and what sucks is officers between a
rock and a hard place they're caught
between a cuomo and a constitutional
place in a lot of these scenarios boom
guess which one's the hard place
are you talking about barbell nipples
cuomo we'll get to cuomo's thanksgiving
orders which by the way
i will not comply i don't know if that
means i'm going to be banned because
i'll be making mary
but uh and people have said if you make
merry at thanksgiving you're gonna have
a much quieter house
at christmas like oh i see an empty
crutch by the fire go
screw yourself listen we're going to
celebrate thanksgiving and
uh so here's another example in
honeymoon beach right there were people
protesting california they had the
overnight curfew which is kovad which i
don't understand how a curfew helps
kovid exactly i'm not sure i guess the
science shows
covet has to sleep too but none for the
riots
no well i mean maybe it did sleep
because that's off they take off shifts
so here are some people in huntington
beach in california look you're not all
sm
spineless surfs uh protesting the uh
covid lock down in honey in beach
not only no crimes those flags didn't
even touch the ground accidentally
beautiful that's wonderful then here's
another one again we're talking about
what can you do acts of civil
disobedience know your rights if you run
a business you can run your business
understand the authority that people do
or don't have to shut it down
understand your right to peaceably
assemble and protest to petition these
are your
rights right now i know a lot of people
want to say that you don't have these
rights
they didn't go away and they don't oh
they're not only afforded
to uh members of the black lives matter
aunt if a black bloc group just to be
clear
as a matter of fact it even applies to
polish americans with eyes that look
like upside down quarter moons here's a
polish american who was comparing the
lockdowns to
uh eastern europe i love this guy
right now focus on the united states of
america
which we witnessed hand
all this steve bannon have been going on
with the election
they want to take it over by
fraud by the fraud
how the communism and socialism work
it's beautiful idea but it's actually
inhumane system yeah yeah i would tend
to agree
people say religion religion is the
cause of all wars
i don't know if you're counting
religious atheism
but if you're counting marxism but
people who live under communists will
understand that
and uh here's another one too this is
something people miss they think it's
just in the united states
this is worldwide the difference is the
united states is the only place where
you have a voice
left so that in and of itself is very
important as it relates to civil
disobedience
in europe places like the bbc people say
i get my news from unbiased sources like
the bbc
do you mean funded by the british
government in canada
cbc you mean nationally funded news
you don't need to go to venezuela to
find it and so people who are protesting
right in a lot of these european nations
they're just not allowed to have a voice
so you don't see it and of course
i constantly get uh these violations on
twitter in accordance with german law
well the last one we got was japan it
was generally very upset with one of
your posts oh really yeah
go back to stealing hip-hop and
skateboarding japanese culture
is if you are the only other culture
that has skateboarding hip-hop
and baseball you're america light
you just don't have guns and that's
because you wouldn't know how to use
them
show about the tentacle porn yeah
[Laughter]
we have freedom we have the first
amendment we have the second amendment
you have used panty machines oh good for
us very good win
innovators a godless society
[Laughter]
they have people whose job in japan it
is to push you in the subway did you
know that yeah
they're certainly people packers they're
so they're so
full there's a kid in there get the fat
ass in the subway
do you think those people are not
petitioning because now they're keeping
people like eight people per se
like do you think people still want us
to push for them
we don't need to pack them but do you
still want the comfortable push
look we're worried about restaurant
tourists restaurant tours hairdressers
in america
but what about the japanese subway
pusher economy right
now they need jobs those jobs you can't
do anything else with those except go to
prison maybe they can push each other
onto the third rail
oh okay
um we don't know this happens across the
globe
berlin still can't get it right here's
an anti-lockdown protest in berlin
and uh then as the camera pins you'll
see how they still treat their people in
germany
i look protest peace peaceful
okay it doesn't look like they're
burning
and the fire hoses no no that's vodka
it's a party and the firehouses are
gonna are we going to send the german
shepherds
we start in this case there's a lack of
irony
perhaps we send rottweilers maybe that
would be you know like a flip
like a spy versus spy kind of violation
of rights
berlin you still don't get it right i'm
keeping my eye on you
i thought we stopped using water cannons
in the 70s bad optics
no they didn't the place that likes to
talk down to america while they have
brown outs horribly
skyrocketing energy costs and they still
fire hose their protesters
i do want to say that every other
article i read on any kind of
left-leaning site you know you know we
talk about how you read a lot of the
kind of what the other side is saying
yeah is they just selectively taking
european countries and just being and
brow beating the [ __ ] out of americans
being like look angela merkel she gave
everything to everyone and all of their
dreams came true and then the next day
they're like
germans are the worst and they have
nazis in the government and then the
next day they're like
they crushed kovid and then the next day
oh they didn't do so good like
yeah they crushed covert how fire hoses
it's amazing the pressure you can get
when you remove the eco nozzle
you take off little rubber gaskets you
can really do some harm to people just
trying to
eat some paella to diner well you know
covet doesn't thrive in dead bodies
so it really doesn't that's true unless
you're swimming in them because they've
been fire hosed with a mass
shallow grave yeah germany i'm sorry i
don't care i don't care what germany has
to say and this is something else that
was interesting people have
we've talked about sweden and this is
something that i will tell you
i didn't even refute because i didn't
think to do
uh the research just because i didn't
know it was so consequential we talked
about sweden had no lock down today
right right there's an actual measure
it's kind of like the economic freedom
index i don't know the name of it
someone can tell me you can tell me in
chat
but they have an index that shows how
free societies have been versus how
stringent the lockdowns have been right
and sweden is very free and so
you have a lot of these people on the
left to go yeah but sweden didn't do
nearly as well as their neighbors in
finland and norway
right now we know that sweden is not as
bad as italy and spain sweden's better
than some worse than some but they
haven't seen the crippling effects to
their economy right
so i always thought well it doesn't
really matter because belgium norway it
just seems like there's no rhyme well
here's the thing
if you actually look at norway and
finland they had less restrictions
than sweden that's why so they're saying
sweden didn't they had a less a fair
attitude but they're worse off than
their neighbors who have an even more
less safe attitude they didn't have a
mask mandate
and finland they just got you know what
finland they should just take the one
the terrorists showed up saw how boring
it was and left
they're like this is cold we don't
really want this place
we're looking for something to bomb but
also to pass the time
yeah exactly what i love about this
protest though is that people in germany
seem to have bigger balls than people in
america right now protesting
things that are against some people i
know i'm not saying overall i'm just
saying
that's a huge protest yeah that's
massive for them but they don't even
have that right to begin with you need
to understand too but when i get
violations on twitter i get violations
of german law violations of islamic law
violations in pakistan but these are
countries where
my account would probably be removed if
i were based in their country because i
would be subject to those laws a lot of
americans don't understand this and i
was some you know was raised in canada
if freedom of speech goes here it goes
everywhere that's why the hong kong uh
protesters were singing the national
the american national anthem you may not
like it you may not like how people
exercise their civil disobedience or
their free speech rights here but you
need to understand that is uniquely
american it does not exist anywhere else
you don't get fire hosed down simply for
assembling
now i know some people will say that
donald trump bean bagged some folks but
that's because the steeple was on fire
different strokes here's one that was in
michigan another civil
protest it was operation gridlock uh in
opposition to some of the lockdowns from
governor whitmer this is another
creative way here you go
whoa that being said
like gridlock in lansing it's
inconsequential
i didn't really want to go anyway it's
like an adult snow day
you mean i can't get over to work in
lansing ah i got some calls
and bus
there's two inches of snow it's very
curative uh and then here's another one
do we have this one do we have clip one
e
i do this is another example and it's
crazy that these people
are the rebels this is um a uh well this
is
these people are jewish um or as they're
known if they're practicing jews on
twitter
not welcome oh um this is a secret
jewish wedding with
thousands of maskless people it's
wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey cuomo you better come out and stop
him
right and uh finally here's another
example and i'll be doing an ash
wednesday tomorrow with pastor mark
driscoll so a long form interview their
church has never closed down in phoenix
um it's kind of surprising isn't it that
that we're now at this phase of
rebellion
yeah it is the jewish community got
attacked was that in new york that last
clip
i don't know where that was can we can
we have red believe it wasn't even
yeah oh my gosh i don't know where you
find that many uh that many
uh orthodox jews and those cats in one
closed air in the united states
provo utah inside inside
mount rushmore temple huh
they changed the decor they don't like
change
at least according to rasheeda talib
right she's the one who's saying you
know the jews are everywhere yeah i know
she's true she looks under her bed she
sees jews it's just a dust bunny
stop rashida don't you know it's wrong
to hate
rashida have bad dreams she's asian now
she's george of the jungle
she's a little kid oh you said nothing
all day and that's the one yeah
hey everybody your face audio awaits
face by the way he had his facial
surgery
so yeah smiling is a is difficult
i thought it would be an improvement
it's not yeah
i'm sorry oh look look cnn biden string
of cabinet picks
set stage for new era the thing about
the new era
it's exactly like the same era from four
years ago
yeah that sucked why are we going back
to terrible people doing a bad job
king henry will usher in a new era
i love how john kerry is now in charge
of climate change yeah i thought he was
dead i didn't do it
i really i was secretary maybe not like
in body form but like in career form
i thought everyone was just like nah not
this guy i thought he was in politician
celebrity rehab
uh yeah i thought i really didn't know
that he was still around
that just shows you i mean listen you
guys can say what you want you can talk
about how donald trump had people who
were uh unqualified didn't have
experience but it was certainly a
shakeup
i wouldn't say that you're breaking new
ground by installing
john kerry it's a new era steven
climate change czar next thing you know
they're gonna hire john edwards to set
up the ring doorbell while he cheats on
his wife with pregnant women
this is a party of absolutely oh my god
just degeneracy okay
contrasting the degeneracy of the left
in the new era of biden
uh john mcarthur he has a church in los
angeles and he continued to meet despite
the bans
of course on churches here's actually
how he and i know people think that old
polite white guys
can't be rebels sure uh but this clip is
proof positive
that you need to check your biases good
morning everyone i'm so happy to welcome
you to the
grace community church peaceful protest
[Applause]
the battle it might as well be that
picture of johnny cash just
right there right yeah that's amazing i
thought about that joke all night
perfect delivery right and he just
started crowd surfing praise the lord
and pass the ghost screw yourselves
unconstitutional government oh man
that's pretty i love it
i love seeing that coming out of
california through new song yeah los
angeles
the guy that's going to go out and do
whatever he wants 650
a plate at french laundry restaurant i
don't know it's okay
he's just like you they held the service
at french laundry that's true
he needs to practice what he preached
well he was also masculine
we had a half oyster on the raw quail
egg just can you just get like listen i
like
food but you have to be such an affected
prick
can you go to a place that's expensive
and good and people understand what's on
the menu
nothing bothers me more than when you go
and they go oh yeah and everyone
pretends like they know like oh yes i
always eat the uh
oyster shell on the f quail egg of
course no one has had it ever
there's an aioli in there somewhere
exactly there's even your sous chef is
just going
i don't know you see the guys in the
back are like let's just see how
ridiculous we can
oh they could for sure on the top of a
wafer
right delicious what is what what is
that that is porpoise penis
that is lightly simmered in
a morel truffle sauce you just made this
up to you it's disgusting
also fun to say
very tender what else do you have this
is the appetizer right it's a
three-course meal what are the other
all-purpose peanuts
covered restrictions it's very hard to
get anything other than purple
pork corpus penis gumbo corpus pino
souffle
interrupted a lot of supply lines
it's taking a large toll on the porpoise
community they're they're penisless
people now
we're getting it peta is going to be all
over this they're going to be reporting
this in every country yeah oh my gosh
the purpose because
really too crazy of a fan from mug club
who's gonna show up like i got one
i tried it it's not bad inside my
porpoise penis there's gonna be one in
my office i guarantee you before like
when i go tomorrow there'll be one
we also have the uh full pig roast if
that oh well that sounds good
roasted on a spit yeah and a nice
porpoise penis place
of course no apples there is no getting
away from the porpoise penis
restaurant sir might i suggest you go to
a place that's more your speed
do you mean any place that isn't
porpoise penis that's correct that is
correct yes
um and here's the thing too hey hey
coppers you guys can join too i'm glad
that my half asian lawyer likes this
uh you guys can join in too police
officers yeah
because you know what it means like hey
we went to bat for you when when people
were
were targeting you police officers and
so you know what we went to bat for you
when you were actually
trying to uh do your job and people were
treating you like crap and
you know now it's time to go back have
the back of the people who've supported
you
and not i want to be clear not all
police officers are that way when you
have some police officers coming in and
they are willing to enforce orders that
they know are a violation of people's
rights that's where you need to know
your rights where you say hey you need a
warrant however i would like to see and
we've seen a lot of this
uh the spirit of police officers as
you'll see in some of these segments so
for example in
virginia they passed an unconstitutional
uh gun law yeah and this is actually the
virginia attorney general uh mark
herring he said when virginia passes
these gun safety laws
they will be followed they will be
enforced and talked about threatening
officers who do not enforce this is
basically by the way a ban on a lot of
weapons where you would have to yeah
mandatory i don't even know if they do a
buy-back i was like are you gonna you're
gonna toss me a few no we're taking it
you have that authority not really
but who cares about that anymore because
jeff bezos has my back
um they're saying we're going to punish
officers who do not enforce this
unconstitutional gun law
and here are police officers saying uh
no
if the bills go through is proposed they
will not be enforced they're
unconstitutional we support uphold the
constitution the united states and the
constitution of virginia
and that's what we'll do yeah there you
go thank you very much
thank you i love him and the mall
santa's association of america
you know this is a really just bear with
me on this comic book reference scared
i'll get it got you initially you
remember how in like all the batman
movies there and then the comic books
and everything they're always like
yeah we got uh that guy over there on
the batman file and it's like the
stupidest guy who's like the helen
keller of detectives
he can't figure anything out she was
blind and deaf
i've read her quote and they're like and
her handler was scribbling down ah yes
she says
uh look before you leave helen keller
said that
and they're like they're like oh man we
can't catch the batman
they're like yeah too bad we can't these
anti-vigilance exactly i mean look
here's the reality
if you're an officer who disobeys and
you're told by a northum or someone else
we will punish you the only punishment
is we will fire you right you'll be out
on the street
and that's a reality for what these
officers are so when whenever we're
confronted with an officer who's saying
like look man
okay i'm just going to look over here
and you like walk away but i'm going to
report that it happened
like that's them making sure that they
can put food on their right they're on
their work
which is why we have to focus our ire
not just on pushing back
with officers and telling them hey be on
our side but then remembering that the
person who is pushing them to do that
the person pushing them to the end of
the plank right into this situation
are the politicians who were allowed
into office right so it's just remember
that as a problem and that's what that's
why we have to get back to the
constitution that's why you also need to
understand what your rights are and
what is what is the constitution tells
you which rights cannot be violated and
that's why i don't believe that i need a
permit it's the second amendment now
that's a law that people obviously
infringe upon in different states
but it shall not be infringed period and
i know you can get the idea of concealed
carry however you do have the right
to have thanksgiving dinner in your own
home i'm sorry yeah that's i don't care
what a governor says that's my god-given
right and so
if a police officer comes in and breaks
it up as we've seen because you're
you're
hasidic jews and they say you can't be
more than 10. well first off good luck
finding any
home in new york in queens with hasidic
jews that has less than 10 people
second you don't have the right to do
that so listen hey jews with the
curly sideburns i don't know i don't
know many of you but we got your back
you have the right absolutely and in
this case this isn't just like one or
two people doing this 73 counties so far
have set up this kind of sanctuary
county where they're saying look if
these laws pass they're unconstitutional
we're not going to enforce them not one
or two right 73 counties in virginia
right i love it i love seeing that yeah
they're just saying no we're not gonna
do it yeah
we're not going to go remember when
people said they said hey they're coming
for your guns and we're not coming for
your gun right when we pointed at a hell
of versus dc where
actually the sending opinion said you
have no right to own a firearm
whatsoever
not some kind of scary assault weapon
which you don't even know what that
means necessarily but even this just
an old-fashioned wheel gun no there are
some peop they believe
in the hell versus dc descending
opinions i don't have a right to have a
firearm period
even here carrying around in my own in
my own property in my own home yeah and
then people said they're going to come
for your and people said no
why are you why are you fear-mongering
now you actually have
secretaries you have governors saying go
to the homes and take those guns and you
have someone who could be president
united states joe biden who said that
he'll make vader or work his guns are
who said hell yes it'll be a mandatory
buyback
which by the way okay i i will comply i
will sell
back any firearms that i have personally
purchased from the federal government
i will sell them back to you that works
kept a receipt right and by the way the
good news is that we know
democrats support us in not enforcing
these laws and you know how we know that
is because they set up sanctuary cities
not to enforce immigration laws and they
also said that stuff that was federally
illegal was totally fine in their state
they're totally on board with this so we
should just do this across the country
so there you go
if you have coming together if you have
a legally owned firearm that all of a
sudden became illegal because of
a tyrannical governor what you just do
is take your pile and toss it into the
closet of an illegal immigrant
uncle samson on the wiser fair sanctuary
city thanks for wearing closet yeah
there we go if you don't put it in a
sanctuary city
then you're just they're going why don't
you put all these guns in jorge's closet
no that's not
doesn't have not
want to get coveted so you're available
doing thanksgiving that's your right
yeah yeah that is absolutely right but
we've moved from public places to
private homes
we've moved think of how the goal posts
have moved two weeks public places
i don't know when they first said two
weeks if they were actually saying the
mask at that point no when they first
started the two weeks they said don't
wear masks they do more harm than good
that's what fought you said
but they said two weeks social
distancing flattened the curve right and
then i sent it to several months
and now we have a tally that they keep
on cnn like a never-ending ticker
with two flu seasons right two flu
seasons that includes any and all deaths
with people who die
with kovid and now we've moved the goal
post from okay we went two weeks
public places then we went okay two
weeks now we're shutting down business
businesses for months
and now we're saying actually you cannot
in some of these states we're going to
enforce
that you cannot celebrate thanksgiving
in your own home even if you wear mask
which by the way we said didn't work and
the largest study we have on masks
homemade cotton masks from denmark show
that they don't work
not saying surgical masks don't work in
a medical
context right but the kind of mask that
you have that you got off of some
facebook ad that doesn't actually have
any kind of a filtration system
you're probably breathing in asbestos
you know this one pisses me off the most
i know you're going to get some details
but this
this if you want to tell me this isn't a
great idea for you guys to get together
but do what you want to do because
you're a free american citizen i think
it's a fantastic idea right that's
fantastic
if you lock this down i i swear to you
if i lived in a state that did this i
would be in prison right now
you have no authority to tell me who can
come to my house and hang out hold on a
second
by the way hit the notification bell
yeah uh i want you to notification bell
if you're subscribed we do it we didn't
do it yesterday obviously but uh
weekdays at 10 a.m eastern i appreciate
the whole you sounded like dirty harry
just then
yeah why would you be in prison gerald
because i would violate the order and i
would publicize it oh okay i would
absolutely put two middle fingers up to
gavin newsom if i lived in california
with a picture of me
and as many people as i could squeeze
into whatever freaking small house that
i had that cost a million dollars in los
angeles you know what makes gerald
really tough right now it's his nautica
pajamas you know if he was
if he was wearing anything else i
wouldn't believe him yeah a little
sailboat
next time no i i really just
protested cops and his modric shorts
gerald
you raised a really good point which is
the civil disobedience in any of these
types of protests whether it's the
over curfew or whatever these rules are
they naturally involve
a decision that a law is
unconstitutional or immoral
so you are we are acknowledging that
there's kind of dissonant
ideas there that you know typically
conservatives are the pro-law and order
right except when those laws and that
enforced order are unconstitutional and
they violate fundamental principles
so the idea of saying hey we're going to
stay out past the curfew because it's
unconstitutional
we're acknowledging that you might be
breaking the law the law as it stated
but for the purpose of showing not only
that you won't be
misled by a triangle government or
follow it but also setting up the stage
to challenge that within the legal
system right
it's just like when you saw shelly
luther is when you see other folks who
are saying
we're not going to do it and they take
it to the next level that's when you get
the kind of opinions
like a heller versus dc right where
again only by one vote
remember ted cruz's book talking about
that right not helen keller
she says that uh a wise man
saves for the winter what i felt that in
her tonsils
brilliant she's never going to catch
batman or the sheriffs that decide
that they're not going to follow these
rules right no i think you're and
actually so this happened in in new york
sheriff's so we just saw that in
virginia we're not going to force the uh
with the mall uh
santa mall association of america in new
york some sheriff said hey we're not
going to be going house to house and
enforcing governor cuomo's thanksgiving
rules which by the way his suggestions
are go house to house and break it up
yes yeah you do good luck doing that
the sharks in west side story do we not
remember i thought it was just a couple
of weeks ago that we heard the left side
to fund the police but now i feel like
you know we really need to extra fund
the police
so that they have the ability to go
catch all these it's not the police's
job to save businesses from molotov
cocktails but it is their job to make
sure that a guy in a short hat with
sideburn curls doesn't see his sister
yeah so you can't have extended family
over but you can protest and riot what
is this people are going to get
what point do when we talk about
anti-semitism how about the governor how
about the laws of new york
yeah welcome to new york you know he's
been doing well we don't like jews
they
this summer it's been specifically
targeting the orthodox jewish
communities yeah like literally
walking past other protests right for
you
know
the jewish protest to literally go to
the jewish protest and be like
you guys are doing you got you're gonna
go to the jail hattie wagon time
the jail hold on a second i have to walk
past spanish harlem here what is that
well a few what are a few garbage fires
but
cantors i'm coming for you follow the
white and blue
so the sheriff uh sheriff said they're
not going to enforce it and here's
governor cuomo speaking of
constitutional apparently he's a little
murky in the rule book i think the lead
in his barbell nipples have gone to his
head
saying that they are not real officers
of the law
i believe that law enforcement officer
violates his or her constitutional duty
i don't consider them a law enforcement
officer
because you don't have the right to pick
laws that you think you will enforce
and you don't enforce laws that you
don't agree with
right that's not a law enforcement
officer
see that's what psychologists call
projecting
you don't simply enforce laws because
you want those laws like telling people
they can't celebrate thanksgiving and
not enforce laws because you don't agree
with them like uh stopping arson
yeah and by the way i think he's right
you do have the right as a police
officer not to enforce an
illegal law an unconstitutional law
right there may be some ramifications
initially of course there'll be some
ramifications yeah but you have a right
to do that
uh it depends how you're using the word
right i mean do you have like
you would you be able to go in and say i
should not have been fired because this
thing i did was wrong
maybe but in a lot of states you can get
fired for no reason at all
so if you choose which is not new york
right not new york
but in a lot of different jurisdictions
you may end up having to suffer for this
which is why we need to have we need to
back the blue regardless even
for the especially for the ones that may
engage in something i think you need to
raise your mind a little bit so
it's a little bit lower you hit the bar
and use the lever you get fired for
doing that you get fired come come talk
to me yeah i don't know
where i agree i won't back i won't back
the blue if they go in house to house to
no separate things no no no no no i'm
gonna have a problem with the blue i'm
gonna have a problem with you
because you're not true blue i'm just
i'm just letting you know mostly
individual officers not overall but
i think i think we're getting too far
off the beam because it starts with
does governor cuomo have the authority
to let arson
continue right and deaths and assaults
by the way also on his officers
and then have the authority to break up
orthodox jews celebrating a holiday but
nope by his own logic he doesn't no by
his own logic he does not by his own
logic the fact that he has let these
things continue to happen all summer
under the guise of progressive workness
he is not there's never the chief law
enforcement there's never been more
more exemplary governors as it relates
to
uh elitism you know we always thought
you used to have this sometimes with
sarah palin like those are
those are new york and l.a democrats
we're all flyers like no listen
you have all different kinds of people
in the united states but there is this
view of the coastal elites
and think about it for a second you have
cuomo whose brother
has his own television program which he
does not warrant at all by the way the
only person less qualified
is totally straight brian stelter who
doesn't want to pay nuisance money to
nick sandman
so you have a governor in new york whose
brother has a show he had kovid
and he was out and about roughing up
guys on their fat tire bicycles
and no consequences at all and then you
have governor newsom we go all the way
to east coast west
it's not a hip-hop battle it's an
affected white elitist prick battle well
then they're saying
we're spending 685 a plate at the french
laundry restaurant while we shut
everybody else down
you couldn't create more out of touch
in disingenuous inconsistent elitist
characters in a
film no you wouldn't buy it if the
script can't be like nah nobody's gonna
come on
this guy's still this guy's actually
going to try and send
cops in to break up jews celebrating
purim
and then he lets his brother push a guy
over on a bicycle all right look
put this through rewrites bring me
something americans can buy
could you imagine if we had said like
imagine there had been some
you know parody about gavin newsom going
to french laundry or some other
expensive restaurant and sitting around
people would
you know that that tweet would have been
flagged it would have
yes it would have been defamation
and then oh it's true it's true we're
disappointed
yeah but we're not surprised and i do
want to are you celebrating thanksgiving
to people out there that's another
question
who out there is actually celebrating
thanksgiving if you are hit like right
now as you watch all the
the many many people just hit like right
now if you
are going to celebrate thanksgiving
because as for me in my house
we'll flip the bird um here's governor
whitmer how the grech stole uh christmas
uh but she already took labor day and
july 4th
yeah and thanksgiving probably she just
took labor day because she didn't want
traffic because she had to lower her
boat
so here she is begging with her um
non-binary signer who's still on higher
and by the way non-binary michigan
signer your roots are growing out
sweetheart we can see uh-oh uh begging
people not to celebrate with that this
is governor whitmer saying don't
celebrate with anyone outside of your
household
i want to talk about thanksgiving which
is next week
what if you are considering spending
thanksgiving with people
outside of your household i urge you
to reconsider urge in one hand
why didn't the signer have a mask that's
true i'm so confused
about that that story i didn't finish it
in a quick trip where i told you guys
yeah ball's in the mood not wearing a
mask and you're like man
yelling at me yeah so i took off my mask
and tried to try and you know signify
the sound
yeah and the guy uh working the desk
told me to put a mask on but said
nothing to the angry black guy he was a
white guy
he was like sir can you put a mask on
and i said uh i'm about to leave he's
like okay fair enough
and then the black guy was buying
lottery tickets so he was clearly at the
counter for he arrived
yeah before me and was leaving after not
a word you know there's a lot of
we've heard anecdotally about how a lot
of businesses are really worried because
they're getting cited for having people
in their stores without me even if they
don't care
right but they worry that people that
officers or enforcement officers are
coming in
and then they see people without masks
and they get written up for it and it's
like
if you're a business owner right now
just trying to scrape eye in a freaking
pandemic
you are afraid of your own customers
right that's crazy
in austin i just found all the
businesses that had black lives matter
sign and i just would
loiter until a cop found me without a
mask i'd be like i don't know
he didn't tell me nothing i think you
might need to
make this one sting once at about two
grand yeah
an example of this sorry nature bee cafe
um here's another one our favorite
gepetto in chief he's got no strings to
hold him down
he's a prick uh fauci
again telling people comply only
celebrate with people in your
immediate household the answer is you've
got to use some common sense in the
situation that you're in and i think
when most people are asking
you're in the home the safest thing you
can do
is to confine the activities in your own
home
with the immediate occupants of that
home
no is that your response
because i need to take a drink i was
just going to say that it's
acting as if safety is the only thing
that you only factor in your life
right everybody there's safety and
there's joy there's thanksgiving there's
happiness well yeah
you've got to do other stuff yeah you
have to be able to live your life right
i don't know if
you guys remember but clemson and notre
dame played notre dame beat them the
fans rushed the field everybody's like
i can't believe it these people are
right next to each other they're yelling
they're cheering there was hundreds and
hundreds of them
how dare they they have had no covet
cases from that none so you're telling
me that that can happen
just to be clear no one here is saying
that covet doesn't exist there's none of
that
now let me tell you a story i uh it was
dry it was drive through because there's
only one place that you guys know
there's open like at 4 30 or 5 a.m to
get coffee
and i want to wake up my wife right now
in the in the dogs by using our own
coffee machine so
um i went i was getting coffee and uh
the person there at the drive-thru
young girl maybe 18 maybe 19.
hands she's wearing surgical gloves two
masks
and a vi it looked like a welding mask
and here's the thing
i i said to her and we'll revisit this
later while we're talking about social
media and people in their own echo
chamber she had no idea we say follow
the science okay follow science what's
what are the chances of she looked to be
fit slim
19 20 years old what are the chances of
her dying from cove and i said do you
realize that
your chances of dying from from coveted
statistically scientifically
are are negligible they're almost
statistically nil
she goes no i didn't know what does that
mean i said it means that it's so
infinitesimal that it cannot actually be
quantified
it's basically zero she said oh i
thought and this is what she said oh i
thought it was way
more than that no yeah because anything
would be more
wha how much more than that do you think
it would be
yes you're wrong any answer pick an
answer any answer
one i thought it'd be more than other
absence of a number
right you're wrong but we're the party
of anti-science
right yeah it doesn't help to wear two
masks and surgical gloves unless you're
changing that's why
surgeons take off their i would like to
say yeah exactly unless you're changing
them every time you hand a cup of coffee
to somebody
it's stupid and pointless take it from
gerald you subway sandwich artists yeah
were you at subway
why would you drink coffee in the subway
why did you beat at some point
i like to get my keurig out of the home
from remaining coffee shops no no it's
art
you know what you know and here's here's
the one thing i would say is also
college for this
about some of the progressive policies
they completely ignore the people that
they arguably are trying to protect
right
right you have a lot of folks who are um
because of their own situation whether
they're older they're immunocompromised
whatever it may be
they still have to pay their bills right
they still have to live
their lives and do what they need to do
setting aside the fact that we can do
thanksgiving which is excellent for us
we're all healthy young whatever it may
be not gerald but like the rest of us
right i have not i have not young people
coming over for thanksgiving and you
know what they said they said i don't
really say i don't care i want to
celebrate look
if it's not thanksgiving and christmas
put it this way when people say what's
most important
people say your health now i get your
health but i don't know like when we say
your health means something if you're
not
okay so your health but doesn't mean
that it negates everything else on the
list it's not all negated by
which is the case for most people with
coveter i think i've lost
slightly my sense of taste without me
so i have relatives who said
hey if not thanksgiving if not christmas
with my
with my children with my grandchildren
what what what is worth
the point one percent risk this is it
this is
this is the most joyous time all of my
best memories in my life
are with family thanksgiving and
christmas yeah you're going to sacrifice
that
yeah exactly and by the way health is
not the most important thing otherwise
we would all live in a bubble we don't
living life is the most important family
freedom yeah
freedom is more important family to me
is more important faith is more
important health is very important
again then that's on a sliding scale
aids
pretty bad unless you're magic johnson
seasonal flu
worse for you than covet if you're young
not as bad if you're older no one talks
about that either by the way they have
this death toll right now on cena 257
000 right that includes that only six
percent of those numbers are people who
just had govid right now i'm not saying
you can say that only six percent of the
deaths are from covey but i'm saying
that number is misleading because people
who've shot
shot themselves in the face with a
shotgun are listed in the offer
as well as people who were driving drunk
on a motorcycle
and that's from two seasons we had a
winter before and now we're going into
another winter and we're just putting
you don't do that with
any other seasonal flu any other
seasonal it doesn't happen
it's only right now okay here's another
one too by the way we're talking about
thanksgiving which i will celebrate you
let me know if you will oregon governor
kate brown first i thought it was kate
spade and then i realized she
she killed herself she's the wrong one
different ones my wife tricked me with
that where she's like i need a new
person so we have a very expensive
person because i can't look at it
because kate spade killed herself
how does that affect your person yeah so
i had to buy her another person the
purse have a picture
i don't know it has her decay on it and
then she went and she bought a kate
spade whatever the female queen is to a
wallet i'm like
you said you couldn't because she killed
herself she's like well if they're not
with a wallet now it's to honor her
[Laughter]
and i went to costco and they were
selling they sell purses at costco
purses myself said like something about
kate spade
and right away she goes yeah she done
herself in
sad that's what she said i was like wow
merry christmas
yeah way to help me buy something so
kate brown the oregon uh
governor encouraged people to call the
police
on those who violate lockdown orders for
thanksgiving violators because they
could face 30 days in jail or over 1200
in fines or both hey maybe this is what
turns more black people republican than
anything else
a snitching policy yeah what happened to
that karen actually
in a state that was literally the hotbed
of do not snitch on riders
right do not snitch on riders praise
them
praise them just take your raping we
recommend that you
get an inflatable donut because sitting
is going to hurt for a while but you're
doing it for the greater good
please do snitch on uh poppy and grandma
uh as they put a turkey in the oven
let's make sure that we shut that down
by the way keep in mind this is a state
that just legalized black tar
heroin right right so
banging 10 gram rocks fine
hopefully charlie sheen would be
welcomed with open arms while paula deen
gets her head on a spike
priorities it's just look if between the
sweet potato casserole
and the turkey you smash a window or buy
some drugs
it's fine you just gotta you gotta break
it up you can't just be there
to celebrate you gotta be there for a
drug deal so what you here's what you do
if you wanna get listen okay to
to the most disenfranchised minorities
in the united states we've heard about
and
most disproportionately affected by
these by these uh disease
diseases and these protests here's what
you do here's how you get yours you go
in
you smash a window you take your stuff
okay
take everything that you want the cops
aren't going to do anything then you
turn over
you give the cops the info and you point
to the guy who's making thanksgiving
dinner
and you get yourself a nice little
reward congratulations you are both a
felon and a bounty hunter
you just fooled uncle sam
we always hear about this right oh it
affects it it affects the most uh
disenchanted among us of minorities
you know what you know what actually
minor black americans you have oh you
can take any black americans hispanic
americans
especially hispanic americans have you
seen how many cars there
are in the driveway and on both sides of
the street
in an area that is predominantly latino
backyard
for crying out loud there's no
homeowners association to say you can't
open an
office in your garage it's not an office
it's a bunk bed okay
that's fine they have big families they
come from cultures that we're supposed
to be celebrating as part of the
american melting pot
black americans big families who
celebrate people talk about soul cooking
love it i want them to be able to
celebrate their holidays
same thing with mexican-american
immigrants those who are here legally
mind you
of course my friend smooth manny's
colombian for crying out loud they
copulate like rabbits i don't have to
tell you about the cubans they're the
most fertile people on the planet
they are fertile and buoyant that's what
they've offered to society
that's a good combo you're gonna shut so
now we're all of a sudden though
what do you think would happen if a
white person snitched on a latino
american
family racism for having a big
thanksgiving how do you think that cop
deals with it when he shows up right
yeah white supremacists are doing that
they're gonna go through neighborhoods
and be like yep
remember how people were outraged of the
white lady who was uh being rude to that
guy with the daughter
by the way she was she was totally out
of line right you are now incur you're
incentivizing this
wow i mean i forget is this chapter 7 or
chapter 4 in 1984
right where it's like hey make sure you
walk around and if you see anyone
giving thanks yes yeah write their names
take their photo and give it to the
police i don't know which chapter but
we're certainly past the point where
they just have
a bunch of sex in the apartment you're
like why do i okay let's flip the page
anyone actually read that this is a
bunch of sex in an apartment it's like
okay all right
all right what when does big brother
come in does he watch
he always wants and by the way do you
really think do you really think these
these politicians who want you find
these politicians who want you you don't
like this uh
joe lewis i'm sorry okay stretching you
can get joe lewis get down
this is the joe lewis penis cam come on
hey this is a player
all this talk about porpoise penis um
thank you joe lewis thank you for going
back down he's a good pup do you really
think that these governors do you really
think these politicians you really think
these celebrities are going to actually
honor these rules themselves do you
think they're going to be socially
not let alone celebrating thanksgiving
and of course governor uh newsome at
french laundry which ended up being it
you know it wasn't like 12 people ended
up being 20 something people yeah
600 some 600 something dollars a plate
for purpose penis on the half quail egg
yeah so not even that but politicians
who've been out in the street you've
seen them not social distance you really
think they're going to follow these
rules
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's droplet projecting he actually he
actually
did like uh you know what's that
tracking fields yeah he was actually
projecting putting his own vomit that
was schumer he's like hold on a second
while i talk i'm gonna have my assistant
hold a mini fan
just a quick poll of any of these
politicians who were saying that they
don't want to gather with people outside
of their household
on thursday but on wednesday they were
gathering in their offices with one
hundred percent people not in their
household
that's true tell me a story mr bones i
think it's the people that want to hang
out with them
right and they're like i'm gonna have
like two people let's just make the rule
two
yeah well it's because they actually
think those people want to hang out with
them
um lori lightfoot come on
and by the way again if you think these
people are serious about canceling
thanksgiving here's a per there's no
more perfect example than this harrison
ford of course a known recent leftist
who uh is flying his private plane i
think you have the story
to go pick up his son ahead yeah after
crashing
after crashing he is picking flying his
own private plane to go pick up his son
for thanksgiving
but by the way i don't don't get a twist
of that does not mean that harrison ford
is
on board with all aspects of
thanksgiving as seen by our exclusive
footage
um of this flight get off my plane
just the news wow
jokes on him it's a bird he just flew
away
[Laughter]
a soft land they're flightless you smart
smartass
[Laughter]
he glided down that turkey better not
glide
i just gave him some doves i need
another take
four of these pink fingers are pointing
back at you
you got me on now when i gave
instructions to the team i said you can
make it look really crappy that looks
really good
it looks like gary aldman was a turkey
i thought that was the movie people say
gary oldman can transform yeah he's
really good
he can't you know he's a [ __ ] he can
play
anything and this is something else that
i really want to talk about too that
people missed because this also applies
to the first amendment look
uh i am more libertarian and i've talked
about this before with companies right
saying hey they have the right to they
have the right to
uh act as publishers all they want they
have the right to determine what comment
content is on their platform that is a
private business is right however
that changes when they have protections
of
being not a publisher but a platform and
the the sort of analogy that's been used
before is in a town square so a couple
things i think people don't know
we're talking about lockdowns and
thanksgiving and you see that little ad
about
uh staying home and staying safe when
you go into uh amazon right now
a lot of people don't know this big tech
the most powerful companies in the world
keep in mind more powerful
than the roman empire than any empire i
don't really know a whole lot about the
ottomans
i just know one of them got kicked in a
pit but i do know that's true that's
just sort of
that happened that the more powerful
than any world government than any
empire they
love lockdowns when you look at these
big tech companies companies
like amazon companies like so google's
profits are up and amazon nearly
doubled its profits from lockdown wow
keep in mind
more american businesses have been
shuttered in the last three months
than in the entirety of the great
recession
that our country had so this is another
thing that's important when you have aoc
going we're gonna we're gonna keep
amazon out of new york now in that case
the big business would benefit a local
municipality because they were bringing
in
uh thousands of jobs with an average
salary of 127 000 they said no no don't
bring those jobs and we want to keep
those in bangladesh but we do want to
shut down all the jobs that do exist in
queens or the bronx or any of these
places that aoc claims she's from
depending on the day
we do want to shut down those businesses
and make sure that they are entirely
entirely reliant on amazon let's not let
them be employed by amazon but let's
make sure that they can only get their
goods or services from
places like amazon or google who by the
way lobby to support more government
shutdowns big
government bureaucracy always hurts the
little guy
and helps the big guy you bail out big
banks small banks can never compete you
can't compete with a never-ending supply
of federal dollars
same thing with airlines same thing with
american auto manufacturers
anyone here want to drive a chevy bolt
the answer is
no or you're wrong
[Laughter]
so let me let me i want to point this
out here because big tech supports
lockdowns and there's this unholy
relationship between government and big
tech and a lot of people don't
necessarily understand they
still have some libertarians who i think
are wrong on this who say well it's a
private business
if you don't like it you can uh you can
go start your own like yeah i'm going to
go start my own telephone right
so we'll get to parlor in a second who's
doing very well let me show you this is
a town actually
that actually has a town square a little
town mckinney that i
found lovely a while back when i visited
because i did a show a long time ago i
said these places really exist
so that's a town square now let me
explain to you when we're talking about
the first amendment that town square see
those arrows
those are all individual businesses okay
they can all set the rules
in their businesses as far as what you
can say or do you can't enter if you
don't have shoes or a shirt unless
you're kenny chesney doing a fourth
album that's basically just jimmy
buffett trying to
cover up the fact that you're ooh very
straight can you side swipe
businesses all of these businesses here
can determine what you say or can't say
in their individual businesses that is
their right that's the first amendment
absolutely now you have
the town square right there in the
middle that's the town square
right the public square where you can
say whatever you want you are free to
speak out against the government you are
free to speak
really your mind as long as you're not
actually committing a crime or
lying like when people say you can't say
fire you can't yell there's a fire in
the town square if there isn't because
you could cause a stampede
okay now let's change this however this
is the problem when you have companies
that are now supporting lockdowns and
run everything all of those businesses
that you see
surrounding the town square this is
where we are today in 2020. it's three
businesses
five if you're really reaching we didn't
include twitter because let's be honest
jack dorsey you're not you want a seat
at the club but you're
stable but amazon google facebook you
could probably throw apple in there
now here's some so all of these
businesses now yep sure they can set the
rules as to what you say in their
businesses only
all of these companies have gotten
together and i mean this actual meetings
we've actually been there for some of
them
and agreed to the same policies as far
as what is acceptable and what is not
acceptable speech and it's often based
on a political opinion also let's add to
that
all of these companies own the town
square that's what we have now
zoom out and you have that in every
single municipality in the united states
of america
that is the issue with big tech that is
the issue
with protection under the law the safe
harbor laws and that is the issue
with the most powerful companies the
world has ever seen
supporting lockdowns while you shutter
your businesses
in record numbers they double your when
big companies when the world's most
powerful company ever
doubles its profits and you have record
business shutdowns
yeah what point do you say the
democratic party's not for the little
guy
yeah right and you've got the democrats
in lockstep with these companies saying
yep
shutdowns are fantastic because here you
follow it through right
shutdowns so businesses have to close
down people need the government
more because they need money so that's
the only thing we're talking about right
now is give people money give stimulus
money
and the only way that you can afford to
do that because that's the next logical
question is to tax
rich people that you don't like anyway
yeah right hey look at this on cnn
really quickly by the way
first off i appreciate the gomez adam's
suit but it's not unfortunate
but apparently he's wearing an old
lady's leggings yeah
hey yeah what kind of mask you got in a
granny penny um
but they're a spirit breeze this lady
has a face that's just always upset
it says millions traveling despite surge
in cases in cdc
oh can you believe this millions of
americans celebrating their god-given
rights to visit their nieces
nephews and grandchildren the humanity
we need to shut this down
traveling terrible oh my crap about him
that's so 20 20 traveling
and this brings us by the way to uh
while we're talking about uh uh big tech
this brings us to parlor where i am you
can follow me steven crowder uh
at parlor we'll be doing some more
content there again we're still going to
be on these forms on
on youtube facebook twitter bringing the
fight to the left as long as we still
are allowed access
but it is important to protect your neck
here is something now parlor's been
growing very rapidly
a lot of big names they haven't left the
other platforms but they've been opening
up profiles at parlor and so of course
now they are a target of the media
here is a man on msnbc talking about
why parlor is don't you notice just like
traveling is dangerous anything they
don't like is
dangerous what about what about arson
it can go either way what about uh
parlor oh
shudder to think of it there are a lot
of roadblocks to it on there and once
it's once you're on there it's not very
useful and then the other issue is
you know they are fine with hate speech
and racism and stuff on that platform
but they're not fine with
all other sorts of things um you know
swearing is not really
allowed in some cases nudity is not
really allowed
okay what so that's the claim that
racism as well
but nudity so like youtube is yeah i was
gonna wait wait wait on twitter you can
contrast with uh with places like
facebook and youtube where they allow
child pornography but not to say maga so
i think the uh
contrast is quite clear back to you
lawrence o'donnell stop the damn
hammering
this is the quality programming we can
come to expect from msnbc
so parlor's community guidelines are
pretty clear by the way
they don't allow criminal activity so
for example pornography
where miners might actually be able to
see it right yeah or things like
bots right they they have community
guidelines that are very clear and you
can go and read them
also it's fine kind of funny that
they're lamenting this idea of profanity
like
parlor even though it supports all
points of view actually is designed to
try and promote civility
right so they actually do remove people
for being trolls
or spam or uh or imitating people or
someone who was imitating uh
had a badge for stephen kreider that's
not me no and they removed that
so thank you those are proper
enforcements of because
that's that's a legal way that's illegal
but i find it funny this is the argument
he makes right here about uh i think we
have to
rewind that clip about specifically
parlor allows racism here
so it's a free speech platform uh in
racism only really
and the worry is you know if you're
spending your whole day on parlor
getting inundated with
one thing and then you go into the
universe
go out to the real world you go to the
shop you start talking about politics
and your reality is wildly different
than the actual reality
then we're gonna have problems
societally we're gonna have problems
across the board wait
i'm sorry are you talking about facebook
no twitter he's talking about twitter
yeah youtube i think it's just here
again that story was telling you about
getting coffee and the
lady having two sets of gloves two masks
and a
welding mask um i said you know
your chance of statistical nails she
said i thought it was way worse than
that you know why because she gets all
of her news on facebook
and do you know why she's not educated
as to the actual scientists because
facebook doesn't allow it they ban
science
from actual doctors who've seen actual
patients
unlike fauci who's effectively been a
career politician really at this point
for most his life not saying he's not a
brilliant guy right but they have banned
doctors they have banned
controlled trials on homemade masks from
denmark
right this is something the biggest
trial that we've had the biggest sexual
study that we've had on masks not saying
that the masks in a surgical medical
setting
don't work that's why surgeons use them
they use it once they wash their hands
someone puts
someone else puts on the gloves like
it's homer simpson dealing with the
uranium bar yeah and then when they're
done they peel it off and they toss it
away
that is very different from you grabbing
granny panties with a bungee cord and
wrapping it around your chrome dome
thinking you're protected against
microscopic droplets that couldn't
possibly be blocked by that fabric weave
you
adult so people who live on facebook
would never
actually see this science they would
never actually see the kind of lockdown
measures
that we've seen in sweden or no
even myself it was a victim of this that
places like finland that places like
norway actually had
fewer lockdown measures than places like
sweden because we bought it because the
information is not allowed on facebook
right and then we condemn parlor this
guy saying if you leave parlor
you might go out into the world and it's
a very different place you mean yeah if
we leave
parlor we might actually be more
educated than the remainder of society
who are only on social media platforms
that eliminate
opinions by design yep look let me look
let me let me be really clear with
parliament you can go to their page
right now it says
their about values page it expressly
invites people of
all races genders creeds
period and more importantly any point of
view
so facebook so youtube who got caught
with all that pedophile pornography that
weird stuff going on right
that for some reason wasn't a problem
but if you actually say that
transitioning children giving them
puberty blockers is child abuse
you might get banned depending on how
big your channel is whereas at parlor
they say hey you know what we just asked
that you don't commit fraud we just ask
that you don't break the law
we just ask that you don't dox we ask
you to try and keep it civil because
we don't want you to if you're just
continually harassing people
in non-contributing which you can do on
facebook provided to the left
we're gonna have a problem with you but
we allow outside of that any point of
view
test me on this go to parlor all the
liberals who watch the show i know we
have plenty of them and some of you are
still bleeding from the young turks who
are still watching over there that's the
last time i'll reference them last time
right now go to parlor sign up post your
stories and see if you get throttled
i will i will eat this mug and it is
girthy
it is very good by the way i love how he
drew the line at being able to swear and
post
porn yeah like that was where he was
like ah this is un-american
i can't taste the bad word and i can't
by the way he's not
american ben collins is canadian and i
thought he might be canadian because i
heard him say oat
and then i saw that he worked for msn
canada and i thought okay the two
together
one by themselves maybe he's such a
crappy reporter as you can obviously see
that they sent him to the feeder leagues
in canada
no he's canadian and the reason he
doesn't understand parlor by the way
people who don't know this
canada doesn't allow free speech i come
from canada
it's the country where they find in jail
people for jokes
the friend of mine mike ward of the show
put before a human rights tribunal
for jokes yeah yeah you know what i i i
want people
to live in the parl i want the real
world to be more like the parlor world
and less like the facebook or the
twitter world which means you have no
accountability whatsoever
no transparency and when speaking with
us in front of a congressional hearing
say uh i don't know when i can get the
answer to you
well jack dorsey you can go screw
yourself yeah if he's from canada
if he's from canada you understand why
he wants porn in public because
that's true yeah that's our that's our
times square in montreal yeah we're
stripped
just giant neon purple tits and a hand
going
where do you want to meet for where do
you want to sit and watch the christmas
parade
i don't know i have our four-year-old
sitting beneath the giant neon purple
tits
oh i'll meet you there
that's not still bombed out by all the
biker gangs is it because we don't have
violence in
[Laughter]
you know canada here's there's a level
of just
what we have to be able to get along
with in society is a level of
being offended and then rebutting and
having a conversation
that a platform like parlor allows right
you can have a differing viewpoint
and people are going to necessarily
respond to that and you're going to have
a list like i've seen on parlor i don't
post on
on parlor but i've been on there and
seeing the kind of posts where when
people are engaged
in racism they're being called out by
conservatives about how they're being
racist but then the other you know then
when there are
jokes or like other things that are not
racist that people are saying hey that's
not racist like right yes
let's all have another idea that's the
wild west there is enforcement but
there's actually some kind of a
legal guideline with parlor fraud
pornography
actual systemic harassment what i mean
by that is not you say something someone
doesn't like
but we all know this right on places
like twitter facebook where people they
contribute nothing they create a soccer
account they create a bot account and
all they do is attack and insult people
that adds no value and that's also why
at parlor they have some kind of
identification which
i would also encourage maybe we
incorporate it into our voting system
maybe um so yeah i do recommend that you
guys
go uh check out parliament at least you
know diversify your investments
um do we you know what let's just keep
doing this on youtube and then
afterwards we're gonna play hipster hobo
i know we'll go a little late in uh uh
half-assing bill if you have to leave
you can
after this segment i refuse here
is it's a long uh our last show like
this before tomorrow on ash wednesday
with mark driscoll tune in for that and
then for mug club members we have the uh
laugh along
as we watch the comedy special sarah
coopers everything's fine
i can't believe you did that i've seen
funnier kids make a wish
everything is not fine so um i've seen
funnier documentaries on progeria
wow jesus i didn't know they had ducks
and felt guilty watching it
um i wasn't supposed to laugh so here's
ours
here's another story here because i
don't know why this is a horrible
perfect example of the media having no
accountability right amazon and big tech
and parliament is just racist right they
didn't say it because they think they
have no accountability with media
just like the media is hoping that you
don't remember the polls
so what they do is they just gloss over
it like nate silver bet you regret that
bumper sticker from 2008
it was also 2016. could have been any
election where he's
wrong before 2016. yeah before 2016.
that's right
um here he is talking on some shows
saying the polls got it mostly right
perhaps there are many things that make
polling difficult and so
you just hope to get close and they
usually do get close including this year
for the most part
half-vision lawyer bill richmond does
the prosecutor's case hold water
nope does it hold water
you said it literally in the show notes
bill talked like a muppet
well gerald did you see that chip chip
[ __ ] [ __ ]
chat okay did they get it right
all right so the polls understated i
want to make sure that i get this
correct uh they understand that a
percentage of the republican vote
in uh 48 of 50 states okay
15 of the 16 senate races hmm that
sounds like mostly
and by the way if they're saying that
these are good because remember everyone
kind of acknowledged what was the
argument they were saying
well no it's not 2016. right they're
saying this isn't 2016.
secret trump voter so how do you say now
the polls got it mostly right
when it was widely acknowledged that you
were wrong in 2016 and the margins are
actually worse than 2016
in this election and this isn't even
including all the ballots that just were
run through like you're counting cash in
a back room
so across the presidential swing states
the average error was five points the
senate
seven points oh is that is that seven
points
five points i don't necessarily i don't
know if that's the margin of error gonna
you can i think i already told you guys
hit the notification bell
here's what was most interesting to me
specifically the most
um here you know what i don't even have
my ipad here anymore this is because i
had to roll those clips there you go
uh specifically the most respected polls
from 538 right 538 nate silver
yeah i wonder i would love to see if we
could actually have a google trend on
the sales of nate
silver bumper stickers oh yeah yeah
research i guess it's a reverse hockey
stick we'll ring the reg bell
um so the most respected polls so i took
the polls uh from 538
because here's the thing i say an
average of five points off that's
including trufflogar and rasmussen and
the polls that were actually close to
being right that leaned more
conservative
you take them out the numbers are very
different now they're off by anywhere
from seven to nine
points some would say nate silver's
margin of error
um so i've only taken the ones with an a
some a minus or a or a plus rating okay
uh
florida we'll start with this florida
trump won president trump won by three
3.2 percent the number one ranked
morrist poll according to 538 trust nate
silver
had biden at plus four ah the number two
a plus ranked monmouth had by knit plus
six
number four ranked uh new york times
sienna had buy knit plus three
all of them aside from abc and that's an
outlier for them here they had biden
winning the top pollsters with florida
under counted support by an average of
six to eight percent
wow six to eight percent and here's
something important by the way this is
after they all of a sudden close the gap
coming into election day
right yeah the further you go back
meaning a week or two weeks from
election they were off by 12 points
in many of these states that's insane
that's a victory margin
in like idaho
they were off by 12 points i don't i
mean at that what point do you just say
well we just don't need polls anymore
well they're going to be off by 12. they
got it mostly right
if it's plus or minus 12 that's likely
peaceful and i have to say
even though they're not respected
anymore they were once the gold standard
now they're ranked a b
uh at uh 5 38 so still that's you know
that's a passing grade uh
quinnipiac quinnipiac quinnipiac
something
they were off by 15.
that's happening there in the back room
they're like what is wrong with you know
they're just like beating them like i
pulled the office and that's what we
said no way
that's worse because remember election
night i said i don't know why people are
saying
florida and ohio or swing states through
right and even with i argue ben shapiro
i said
far more surprised if ohio went blue
than texas and i hoped you didn't have
to eat your words on that one
i wasn't sold that's because gerald just
said he didn't believe you
he didn't i believed him but
that's why we'll talk more about sydney
powell uh obviously for those who are
mug club exclusive and take your chat
because
we don't know we're not making
predictions right now we're not making
any promises but i did make the promise
on air
i said florida and ohio are going trump
uh i would say that it was a pretty
decisive victory in ohio uh president
trump won by eight point two percent
ooh that's significant again we have
morris
we're just going the number one through
the top rankings according to 538 trust
nate but breakup is thanksgiving
gathering his last name silver
we don't need to tell you that there are
probably quite a few other silvers in
that household
need to be broken up call cuomo a lot of
curly sideburns so
um morrist had biden at plus four
wrong by 12 emerson
wrong by nine percent new york times off
by nine percent and again the further
back you
get from the election meaning if you get
right up to election day the gaps all of
a sudden closed
but if you were taking the polls from
six days before
two weeks before they were off by 12 13
depending on these 14
which by the way was the exact same
trend with hillary clinton people say
well anything was up in the air with
this election
this is always what happens and there
have been studies that have been
conducted it's not necessarily
been conclusive that polls are used to
manipulate public opinion that they can
actually affect people going out and
voting if they think there's no chance
in winning
or if they think that they're that far
ahead um on election day
we have the final number yeah election
day the top ranked pollsters according
to 538 trust nate
undercounted trump voters in ohio by
eight to 12 percent
three weeks before election date was 10
to 15 percent jesus
hey let me ask you this what if i were
to say hey that mask
it's only uh 88 percent effective
by the way it's less but my point is you
probably wouldn't feel as secure
man with the poles who cares just the
future of the free world at stake uh and
by the way this is something funny
really funny new york times
had it uh off by eleven or ten percent
in ohio
on three separate occasions they read
they did polls they're like i don't know
we've corrected
the secret trump voter oh you did so you
polled
three times new york times america's
most respected publication
and you had biden winning by how close
were you we were about 13 points off oh
how much did trump win by oh over 8 and
you're still employed we don't expect it
to last very long yeah well and how do
you account for a
secret voter yeah right yeah exactly
well they just said it didn't exist
super secret yeah i guess their goal was
to be accurate these polls are as bad as
those like pre-season college football
wait wait
one time i had that that was
uh new york times polled in wisconsin
three separate occasions and they were
off by ten to eleven percent sorry
with your points i was just saying notre
dame's overrated okay that's not true
it says wisconsin y'all historically you
even say that you guys fall more on
average from pre-season rankings than
any other teams here's a century
of wisconsin this is the one that's best
they're ranked number uh
they're a plus ranked by nate silver
trust nate
they undercounted trump voters in
wisconsin by 17
so remember this wow this is when you
had people saying it's over no one has
ever come back from a 17-point lead you
saw everyone in the media saying that no
one's ever come back it's over and you
had some
people who actually didn't show up to
vote because i thought well it's a 7 17
point lead
it was 0.5 in wisconsin 20
000 votes but you mean to tell me that
that won't affect
public behavior if people believe that
their guy is down by 17 points
according to the most respected a plus
plus plus ranked poster according to uh
professional snake oil salesman and
chief nate silver
and then i think they even went out of
their way to kind of lambast these other
pole what trafalgar
i don't know how you pronounce it right
whichever one that was they were saying
all these guys don't know what they're
talking about you can't
crazy these guys and i'm like they
actually got it yeah pretty right
they go oh trafalgar was wrong about the
states that they that they called for
trump in a very close margin by the way
1.5
in states like pennsylvania michigan
were there we know there was no rampant
fraud at least we assumed no one was
watching
but for some reason they're not held
accountable when they had when they had
donald trump losing
ohio by 12 and florida you got those
states wrong and it wasn't within the
margin of error it wasn't even close
all right something else too uh the
house by the way this is a big one uh
the final 538 projection
had democrats gaining seats this was
something that was widely accepted
everyone knew that they were going to be
gaining seats even on the night of
election
fox new fox news
the most trusted name and [ __ ]
fox news is polling it was so bad they
still projected we were there on
election night democrats expanding their
house majority by at least five seats
this is election night
the fox news decision desk can now
project that democrats will retain
control
of the house of representatives and
expand their majority by at least
five seats i hope you can run that
stinger and rewind
we screwed up this surprised me
republicans picked up nine seats and are
actually leading in several of uh the
undecided races still nice going on in
the city that's fantastic here's another
one specific example then we have to go
in maine this is one that a lot of
people now don't remember because the
media doesn't talk about because there's
no accountability yeah they basically
acted
like remember uh republican susan
collins like oh it was just a death
sentence she has no chance not at all
matter of fact there was so susan
collins is a perfect example
there was not a single poll not
one that had susan collins winning some
of them had uh the democrats sarah
getting up by as much as 12
points 12 points susan collins won by
nine wow by nine points i remember a
poll showing collins winning by
nine points nine how many points
how many that's a swing of twenty one
number eight nine
twenty one number nine i think the fraud
went backwards on that one i think they
tried to rig it the other way and they
got they got it all wrong yeah
ah
i always make a simple hitting the d
instead of the r is not a mundane detail
michael
put a decimal point in the wrong place i
don't know son of a [ __ ] someone in
germany's server room is gonna be pissed
so this when people but now that you are
going well the polls are mostly right
now listen
if you were to hold yourselves
accountable media and big tech
you would sit yourselves down and you
would flog yourself with that guy who
was the actor in wimbledon and da vinci
code wearing a burlap sack
you deserve to be punishment you
performed bad your polls were bad and
you should feel
bad and i don't feel bad about taking
some exclusive talk right now behind
mug club exclusive because we can't talk
about sydney power or some of the
election stuff right now uh because it
may be factually maybe ben so youtube
you can go piss off mug club we love you